the rules from the left are very clear
just because they get to do
and say certain things doesn't mean you
get to do or say the same things
and this holds true across the board for
uh in many areas but especially it's
true
for hitler and holocaust analogies as
you no doubt recall democrats and
leftists across the spectrum at every
level spent the past half decade
comparing donald trump to hitler
and his every executive action or policy
proposal to the holocaust
they invoke the nazis at every turn
reflexively accusing their political
opponents of being nazis
i've been called a nazi myself more
times than i can count
in spite of the fact that i've never
participated in any genocide of any kind
to my memory nor have i ever expressed
any allegiance to or affinity with
the nazi party there's no factual basis
for calling me a nazi or you or trump
but it was never about facts for them
when they say nazi they simply mean that
your opinions are bad in their opinion
and the nazis are bad
and therefore since you're both bad
you're the same
that's as far as the similarities have
to go in order to justify
the comparison in their minds and it's
not just with the nazis these are the
same people who will accuse you of
directly causing
hundreds of trans people to commit
suicide if you so much as state that
women don't have penises
these are people who will throw suicide
tragedy death genocide holocaust
around like their water balloons
whatever is required to land a hit on
their ideological opponents
and yet as established none of this
gives you license to do the same
they have different rules they have a
different lane that they run in
and you better stay in your own lane or
there will be hell to pay
marjorie taylor green learned that
yesterday when she uh sent out a tweet
comparing vaccine passports to the gold
star that jews were forced to wear
under the nazis green tweeted quote
vaccinated employees get a vaccination
logo just like the nazis forced jewish
people to wear a gold star
vaccine passports and mask mandates
create discrimination against unvaxed
people who trust their immune systems
to a virus that is 99 survivable
now so that was the tweet
and that is to my mind a sort of silly
comparison
overheated i am very opposed to vaccine
passports but this
isn't the comparison that i would draw
yet green's point here first of all
comparison aside
is correct it is wrong to discriminate
against unvaccinated people and vaccine
passports
are a terrible idea with all kinds of
potentially awful ramifications
whatever you think of the nazi tie-in
the analogy she draws here is utterly
par
for the course people do it all the time
democrats especially but not just them
people everywhere across the internet
are always invoking the nazis and world
war ii
and the holocaust to make their point is
that because they're anti-semites no
see if if they're anti-semitic and
they're nazi sympathizers
then they would support the holocaust
and they wouldn't use it to illustrate
how evil something is
the whole point of the comparison is
that the holocaust
was bad that's the point
the constant nazi analogies are really
just the result of uh
not anti-semitism but a kind of
intellectual laziness and a lack of
imagination
nothing more sinister than that most of
the time
certainly in this case it's not sinister
it's not a big deal
it's not some great evil thing that
marjorie taylor greene has done she's
just done
what everyone on the internet is doing
every day all day all the time
in summary who cares well
the left cares they care about this
hyperbolic nazi analogy this one
outraged them the ones they make all day
every day all the time non-stop are okay
but this one
was beyond the pale marjory teller
green's
tweet set off a day's worth and now two
days worth of
over-the-top hand-ringing outrage
condemnations
solemn conversations about the grave
threat
that marjorie taylor green poses to our
democracy
her tweet was condemned by every
democrat every media outlet even the
auschwitz
museum felt the need to chime in cable
news yesterday featured
many breathless segments like this one
with john berman on cnn listen to this
it is not only a historic it is
abhorrent it's also apparently
allowable under house minority leader
kevin mccarthy who hasn't commented on
it and refused to punish green for past
anti-semitic statements she made
wearing a mask compared to the murder of
six million
people it's so far beyond the realm of
decency it could only
possibly be made worse by comments from
marjory taylor greene
i stand by all of my statements i said
nothing wrong
and i think any any rational jewish
person didn't like what happened
in nazi germany and any rational jewish
person
doesn't like what's happening with
overbearing mass mandates
any rational jewish person i'm jewish
i'm not at all religious and thank god
my family made it to this country
decades before the holocaust but that's
my heritage
and i promise you that congresswoman
taylor green she thinks i'm jewish
so as a rational jewish person let me
just say to marjory taylor greene
don't you dare speak for me not if
you're going to compare health measures
or anything
to the holocaust in a tweet last night
she said
i'm sorry if my words make people
uncomfortable no they don't make me
uncomfortable
they make me sick how dare you
abhorrent it makes me sick
i'm a jew myself says john berman sure
uh he doesn't care about his faith he
says and he's never
said a single word of protest against
any left-winger making a holocaust
analogy
ever but even so he is outraged offended
he's never heard of anything so terrible
in his life
and where are the republicans why aren't
they condemning this they must condemn
condemn it once
condemn this thing that we're pretending
to be upset about condemn it
well don't worry republicans are always
ready to bark like dogs whenever the
left snaps its fingers
and right on time house gop leader kevin
mccarthy issued a statement
condemning marjorie taylor green in no
uncertain terms you said in part
uh quote marjorie is wrong and her
intentional decision to compare the
horrors of the holocaust with the with
wearing masks is appalling
the holocaust is the greatest atrocity
committed in history
the fact that this needs to be stated
today is deeply troubling americans must
stand together to defeat anti-semitism
and any attempt to diminish the history
of the holocaust
what a pathetic little worm this guy is
house minority whip uh steve scalise
also condemned
so did liz cheney of course calling the
comments vile and
evil and lunacy
evil it's evil now i mean there are a
lot of evil
everyone on the internet is evil now you
included
everyone cbs has a report on other gop
leaders who joined in the
condemnation parade quoting out says a
spokesperson for nancy pelosi responded
that the speaker
quote has for decades spoken out against
anti-semitism and anti-semitic attacks
including just yesterday
citing a tweet from pelosi dancing
against anti-semitism
leader mccarthy waited days to even
issue a statement in response to one of
his members demeaning the holocaust
and he was like demeaning the holocaust
oh yeah we wouldn't want to demean and
insult the holocaust
what does that even mean demeaning
the holocaust is a horrific horrible
thing
you wouldn't want to demean it
uh quote and he clearly intends to
continue to welcome marjorie taylor
green in the gop
and shield her from any real
consequences or accountability for her
anti-semitism
uh this according to pelosi spokesperson
drew hamill leader mccarthy
silence has spoken volumes about his
allegiance to the most extreme elements
of the gop conference
green's recent comments may have
precipitated response from mccarthy
following criticism from prominent
republicans
quote please educate yourself so that
you can realize how absolutely wrong
inappropriate is to compare proof of
vaccination with the 6 million jews who
are exterminated by the nazis
you are an embarrassment to yourself and
the gop according to matt brooks the
executive director of the republican
jewish
coalition he said in a tweet on tuesday
morning
jeff miller a prominent gop lobbyist and
close friend of mccarthy
who sits on the holocaust memorial
museum council slammed green in a tweet
on tuesday saying he would be
happy to arrange for her to visit the
u.s holocaust museum quote
then maybe going forward you wouldn't
make any more disgusting ignorant and
offensive tweets
if i'm wrong and you're not ignorant
about the holocaust then you are
disgusting
now you know i could go and and and
check to see if any of these blathering
phonies and idiots ever said anything
like this to
any democrat who has invoked the
holocaust or hitler but i don't think i
need to check
because we all know the answer they
didn't we also know that these
republicans being good little puppies
and doing as they're told
will never actually succeed in
satisfying their masters
even though republicans condemned as
they were instructed to and did it
within hours of the offending tweet
still wasn't enough wasn't fast enough
wasn't passionate enough
as wolf blitzer and dana bash back on
cnn
made clear why do you think it took
these republican leaders
so long to condemn these outrageous
comments from this congresswoman
it's a difficult question to answer and
we haven't been able to answer
to ask any of the leaders themselves why
it took them so long
for you and me it's not just political
it's not just the story we're covering
this is a very personal issue given the
fact that both of us
we lost family during the holocaust
that's right and
and none of this should be political
this isn't about political party
this is about right and what wrong and
and ignorance
and whitewashing uh something that was a
stain on humanity in in human history
and yeah um i mean the fact that
auschwitz had to come out with this
incredibly powerful tweet
my grandparents were nazi refugees
my great grandparents perished at
auschwitz
uh yeah you know maybe a yellow star was
something that was
um you know yellow star was horrible
being uh gassed which is what my
great-grandparents
were is a whole different thing and to
compare that to the notion of
public health and wearing a mask is just
beyond the pale i can't imagine what
it's like for you wolf
your your parents were in slave labor
camps yeah
the really offensive thing is that these
soulless sociopaths would use their own
dead family members to score political
points because that's what they're doing
here
now if you think i'm being harsh then
please please just show me the clip from
two years ago
when wolf blitzer and dana bash sat
there and tearfully condemned aoc for
accusing trump of running literal
concentration camps
which she did it wasn't even a
comparison she wasn't saying oh it's
like
she was saying he actually has
concentration camps
blitzer as a man whose family perished
in real concentration camps must sure
have been
surely have been offended by that if he
was offended by marjorie taylor green's
comments which were
innocuous in comparison but no such clip
or segment exists
and we all know it and that's why
republicans
though they will never stop playing this
game must stop
playing this game what what what the
when the left demands that you condemn
your own side
for doing the things that they do and
saying the things that they say
the correct response is to laugh in
their face or ignore them
if you like or you know what outright
defend
whatever they want you to condemn purely
out of spite
that's fine too because you know really
any response
any response is better than doing as
you're told
and giving them what they want it is not
principle there's no principle here
you are cooperating with these
disingenuous dishonest frauds
taking part in the charade allowing
yourself to be used
emboldening them supporting them
implicitly or explicitly
and none of that approaches the realm of
principle
maybe you do it out of fear maybe you do
it out of stupidity maybe you do it out
of self-preservation
or maybe you do it because you haven't
thought it through whatever the
motivation it is not the more virtuous
path
if you're an elected republican and you
work with marjorie taylor green
every day and she says something you
disagree with
you can go and speak to her directly
personally i'm not saying you have to
agree with and support everything that
everyone on your side says
and does i'm saying that condemnation as
a public display
as public ritual has to stop
it's the same principle that holds true
for public apologies
i'm against those two i'm not saying
that nobody should ever
apologize ever again i'm not against
apologizing
in principle i'm saying that apologizing
to the public
in this ritualistic fashion because the
mob told you to
is never the right thing
it also will never have the result
you're hoping for
you'll never receive forgiveness through
a public apology
just as you'll never get any credit for
a public condemnation
so stop and grow a backbone
and smarten up please dear god
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content